Hallo und herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit, dem Podcast-Projekt von DLR und ESA. Und mein Name ist Tim Pritlove. Und es ist die zweite Ausgabe, die mal nicht aus Deutschland kommt, sondern aus Holland. Ich befinde mich immer noch auf dem Gelände der ESTEC, dem großen ESA-Zentrum in der Nähe von Den Haag. Und nachdem es in der letzten Folge primär um das ATV-Projekt ging, was hier zwar verwurzelt ist, aber ein übergreifendes Projekt ist, was auch viele andere Zentren betrifft. Gibt es etwas, was hier im ESTEC gemacht wird, was sonst nirgendswo gemacht wird? Hier wird viel getestet und darüber wollen wir heute reden, über das ESTEC Test Centre. Und als Gesprächspartner dazu begrüße ich Jörg, Jörg Wiener. Hallo.
Ja, hallo. Ich begrüße euch auch und freue mich, dass ich heute ein bisschen dazu beitragen kann.
Super. Was ist denn deine offizielle Arbeitsbezeichnung eigentlich hier beim Test Centre?
Ich habe eine interessante Arbeitsbezeichnung, die ein bisschen in meinen Aufgaben über das Test Centre hinausgeht. Die Arbeitsbezeichnung heißt HET, also Chef des technischen Netzwerks für Zentren in Europa.
Das heißt, hier geht es sozusagen auch um die Vernetzung aller anderen Zentren auch noch?
Ja, in der Tat. ESA ist ja sehr viel auch über die Nutzung und gemeinsame Nutzung von Raumfahrtressourcen, die wir in Europa haben. Eben nicht nur in der europäischen Raumfahrtorganisation, sondern auch national. Und eine unserer wichtigen Aufgaben ist eben auch diese Nutzung zu koordinieren. Und das ist eine meiner Aufgaben hier in ESTEC.
Welche Zentren müsste man da noch nennen?
Ja, wir kennen ja nun im DLR auch sehr viel Raumfahrtexpertise angesiedelt in Instituten, im Deutschen Raumfahrtkontrollzentrum in Oberpfaffenhofen zum Beispiel, in Testeinrichtungen, die wir im DLR haben. Also das DLR an sich bietet schon Raumfahrtexpertise per se. Gucken wir in andere Länder, Frankreich zum Beispiel, das ein großes technisches Zentrum in Toulouse hat, wo also auch sehr viel Expertise zum Satellitengeschäft existiert, die ein großes technisches Zentrum für Launcher-Expertise in Evry nahe bei Paris haben. Schauen wir nach Italien, wo wir auch einige technische Zentren haben, zum Beispiel auch in der Nähe von Rom. Also alle diese Aktivitäten versuchen wir heutzutage zusammenzubringen, um bestmöglich die Ressourcen, die wir heute in der europäischen Raumfahrt einsetzen, auch zu nutzen.
Interessiert mich, was macht sozusagen die Kommunikation aus? Also was muss man da zusammen organisieren? Wie schafft man das, diese doch sehr unterschiedlichen Kulturen und Schwerpunkte zusammenzubringen?
Na der gemeinsame Anker sind sicherlich die Raumfahrtprojekte, die wir in Europa haben. Wir kennen ja nun einige Raumfahrtprojekte in der europäischen Raumfahrtorganisation. ATV ist ja zum Beispiel in der letzten Folge als Beispiel darüber gesprochen worden. Es gibt aber natürlich auch sogenannte nationale Raumfahrtmissionen. Deutschland hat da welche, Frankreich hat da welche. Die Länder beteiligen sich selber und auch die ESA selber auch an wiederum internationalen Missionen, mit NASA, also ISS zum Beispiel ein Beispiel. Alle diese Missionen und auch zukünftige Missionen stellen natürlich technologische Herausforderungen, weil sie meistens an die Wissensgrenzen der Menschheit heute herangehen. Wir also mit fortschrittlichen Technologien versuchen müssen, die Antworten zu finden. Jeder, der in dem Geschäft unterwegs ist, weiß, dass fortschrittliche Technologien einen hohen Ressourceneinsatz bedeuten, also viel Geldeinsatz. Das versucht man natürlich zu optimieren, indem man zusammenarbeitet. Das heißt zum Beispiel versucht Duplikationen von technischen Kompetenzen, wenn möglich, zu vermeiden. Wobei natürlich man auch immer im Hinterkopf halten muss, gewisse Konkurrenz, gewisse Vielfältigkeit im Ansatz hilft natürlich auch weiterzukommen, hilft natürlich auch die Innovation zu beschleunigen. Also man muss da sicher die Balance finden zwischen dem, was vom finanziellen optimal zu etablieren wäre und dem, was technisch und wissenschaftlich die Zielsetzungen optimal fördert. Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist natürlich klar, unter den heutigen haushaltspolitischen Gegebenheiten ist Kooperation und gemeinsame Nutzung von Ressourcen eine ganz wichtige Angelegenheit.
Ja, jetzt sind wir aber beim ESTEC, eine ESA-Einrichtung. Hier sind verschiedene Facilities untergebracht. Labore, ein bisschen Verwaltung, andere Dinge. Ein großer Teil davon macht das ESTEC Test Centre auf. Aus was ich jetzt auch gerade die Gelegenheit hatte, mir das erste Mal live anzugucken. Viele große Hallen mit allerlei interessanter Technik mit drin. Welche Rolle spielt denn das Test Centre insgesamt jetzt im ESA-Universum? Welche Stellung hat das?
Wozu braucht man das? Ich sag mal, unsere Philosophie bei der Implementierung von neuen Raumfahrtprojekten ist natürlich, dass wir sicherstellen wollen, dass alles, was wir in den Weltraum hineinschießen, um das mal so etwas lapider auszudrücken, dass wir davon vorher im Vorfeld überzeugt sein wollen, dass das auch technisch einwandfrei funktioniert und dass wir dieses technische Operations auch garantieren können. Und wie macht man das? Wie macht das jeder? Indem er das, was er erstellt und produziert hat, überprüft. Eine Qualitätssicherung, die man auch aus der Industrie, aus anderen Bereichen kennt, wollen wir natürlich auch sicherstellen. Die Qualitätssicherung in der Raumfahrt ist natürlich nur durch einige zusätzliche Parameter, die man normalerweise bei erdgebundenen Anwendungen nicht kennt. Wie da zum Beispiel der Weltraum mit extrem niedrigen Temperaturen und extrem hohen Temperaturen, also extremen Temperaturschwankungen, mit einem Vakuum, mit einer geringen bis gar nicht vorhandenen Gravitation, mit extremen Strahlenbeeinträchtigungen der Materialien und auch der Menschen, wenn sie dann im Weltraum sind. Also alle diese Faktoren, die wir so originär auf der Erde gar nicht kennen, weil unsere Atmosphäre uns da im Wesentlichen, ich sag jetzt mal, vorschützt, die müssen wir natürlich versuchen, auf die Objekte einwirken zu lassen, die wir nach oben bringen, um im Vorfeld abschätzen zu können, ob sie mit diesen Bedingungen überhaupt zurechtkommen können oder nicht. Um diese Philosophie umzusetzen, bedarf es eben bestimmter technischer Einrichtungen, die wir hier im ESTEC Test Centre zusammengefasst haben.
Aber alles kann man ja nicht simulieren, oder?
Na, wie das Wort Simulation schon sagt, das ist also eine Annäherung an die Realität, die mehr oder weniger gut gelingt. Das Thema Mikro-, also Gravitation und nicht Vorhandensein von Gravitation zu simulieren, ist also schon allein eine Wissenschaft für sich. Und das ist sicher ein Anspruch, den wir hier gar nicht erst erheben, weil wir das nicht können. Wir können also nicht das nicht Vorhandensein von Gravitation simulieren. Und das ist ja auch einer der Gründe, warum wir überhaupt die ISS haben. Das ist halt, wenn man so will, in gewisser Weise ESTEC 2 im Weltall jetzt, die es uns ermöglicht, diesen Faktor dann auch noch in bestimmten Fragestellungen mit einzubringen. Andere Weltraumfaktoren, wie zum Beispiel Temperatur, wie zum Beispiel Vakuum, können wir hingegen sehr gut simulieren. Und kommen da in der Simulation schon sehr, sehr nahe an das heran, was im Weltraum wirklich zu erwarten ist. Und wenn man sich die unterschiedlichen Faktoren alle ansieht, dann ist sicher für das Funktionieren der Satelliten, was ja für uns das Anliegen ist hier in ESTEC, ist sicher der Faktor Mikro-Gravitation oder nicht vorhanden sein von Gravitation ein unklar geordneter Faktor. Für uns spielen mehr die Faktoren eine Rolle, die wirklich auf die Technik einwirken können. Und da ist Temperatur, da ist Vakuum sicher ein Kriterium, das wir ganz dringend mit überprüfen müssen und wo wir sicher sein müssen, dass das, was wir konstruiert haben, diesen Bedingungen auch standhält.
Ich muss glaube ich auch nochmal dazu sagen, es geht ja hier auch weniger um Experimente im Labor, wie das jetzt auf der ISS der Fall ist, sondern hier geht es ja konkret um das Geteste des Gerätes, was es denn mal ins Weltall schaffen soll, um dort dann seine eigenen Experimente durchzuführen oder Messungen oder was auch immer Aufgabe der jeweiligen Mission ist. Das heißt, hier im ESTEC läuft eigentlich alles durch, was später mal auf der Rampe landet und ins All geschossen wird.
Ja, in der Tat so. Also alle Satelliten, die von der Europäischen Raumfahrt Organisation und auch andere technische Einrichtungen, die ins Weltraum geschossen worden sind, jemals geflogen worden sind, werden sind und werden hier im ESTEC Test Zentrum validiert, bevor sie dann wirklich auf die Rampe kommen, wie du das formuliert hast, und in den Weltraum geschossen.
Alle im Sinne von jedes Einzelne oder alle im Sinne von alle Typen?
Also wenn ich von der Vergangenheit bis heute gucke, dann muss ich sagen, im Sinne von jedes Einzelne. Weil der Satellit an sich ist heute immer noch ein Prototyp in dem Sinne. Also wir bauen im Prinzip keine Redundanzen. Also wir wiederholen nicht den Bau von Satelliten. Und insofern ist jeder Satellit ein Prototyp, ein Einzelstück. Und wie das immer so ist, jedes Einzelstück muss überprüft werden. Man kann nicht davon ausgehen, nur weil man mal etwas Ähnliches gebaut hat, dass es sich vielleicht genauso verhalten wird, wie das, was man jetzt gerade aktuell baut. Also da ist wirklich die Vorsicht...
Auch wenn man jetzt einen Verlust hat, ich meine so Kryosat zum Beispiel, da ist ja die erste Mission verloren gegangen. Der Kryosat 2 war dann nicht nur der Nachfolger, der war auch anders.
In der Tat ist das so. Und das kann man sich auch ganz leicht dadurch klarmachen. Der Entwicklungs- und Bauzeitraum eines Satelliten kann gut und gerne bis zu zehn Jahre umfassen. In manchen Fällen sogar noch länger. Selbst ein Nachbau passiert also nicht innerhalb von einem Jahr, sondern da geht wieder eine Zeit ins Land. Und wenn man sich schon anguckt, was man so an Technologieentwicklungen, ich sag mal, auf der Erde so mitbekommt, wie schnell sich zum Beispiel die Computergenerationen weiterentwickeln, wie schnell sich in der Biologie Entwicklungen ergeben, dann sieht man schon, dass man teilweise gar nicht mehr die gleiche Technologie einsetzen kann, die man bei dem Originaldesign hatte, weil es die gar nicht mehr gibt, weil die gar nicht mehr zur Verfügung steht.
Und weil wahrscheinlich auch neue wissenschaftliche Fragestellungen aufkommen.
Und dann kommen natürlich auch neue Möglichkeiten hinzu, also technische Möglichkeiten, die dann wiederum ein vielleicht besseres wissenschaftliches Ergebnis bringen. Und wenn man natürlich in der Zwangslage ist, dann eine Mission zu wiederholen, wie zum Beispiel bei Kroyosat, dann versucht man natürlich auch zwar mit der gleichen Fragestellung, aber vielleicht dann den wissenschaftlichen Output doch zu verbessern, gegenüber dem Originaldesign, was man gemacht hat. Das ist sicher noch was völlig anderes als ein völliges Neudesign, wo man auch eventuell eine neue wissenschaftliche Fragestellung angeht. Also, Curiosity 1 und Curiosity 2 liegen sicher in diesem Sinne sehr, sehr dicht zusammen, wenn ich das mal vergleiche mit einem anderen Extrem, Herschel oder Planck, also zwei andere wissenschaftliche Missionen, die sich damit beschäftigen, im Prinzip den Urknall besser zu verstehen. Also zwei völlig andere Designs der Satelliten, und da kann man nicht von dem einen auf das andere schließen oder was auch immer.
Also alles muss getestet werden, aber in Zukunft ist das schon denkbar?
Natürlich, mit jedem Test entwickeln wir auch weiter unsere Simulationsmöglichkeiten. Alle Ergebnisse der Tests werden natürlich auch versucht, hinterher im Computer wiederum zu simulieren, um zu sehen, ob man mit den Methodiken und den Simulationstools, die wir heute haben, im Prinzip Testergebnisse reproduzieren kann oder nicht. Und da sind wir natürlich heute auch schon viel weiter gekommen als früher. Während man früher einen Test vielleicht vier-, fünfmal durch eine Facility, also durch eine bestimmte Technik, Einrichtungen durchlaufen ließ, reduziert man das heute vielleicht schon auf ein-, zweimal, weil man mithilfe der Simulationen, die man zwischendurch machen kann, schon sehr gut bestimmte Fehler im Vorfeld herausfiltern kann und das dann nicht mal nötig ist, das wirklich nochmal am lebenden Objekt zu überprüfen. Also das ist eine Kombination von Simulation und Test. Und die Simulation ist heute schon so gut, dass wir zumindest die Anzahl der durchzuführenden Tests reduzieren können. Unter Experten gibt es natürlich einen Streit darüber, ob die Simulation jemals mal einen Test wirklich ersetzen kann oder nicht. Ich denke, das ist akademisch, das wird die Zeit zeigen. Da kann man eine Meinung zu haben oder nicht. Das ist heutzutage relativ unerheblich für uns. Unsere Politik ist ganz klar, wir brauchen Tests zur Verifizierung. Natürlich benutzen wir Simulationen so viel wie möglich, weil das auch Kosten spart gegenüber den wirklichen Tests.
Aber erst der Test gibt einem wirklich auch die Gewissheit.
Aber der Test gibt uns die letzte Verifizierung.
Aber wenn man jetzt an so Projekte wie Galileo denkt, da ist ja eigentlich davon die Rede, viele identische Satelliten hochzuschicken, die ja eigentlich, naja, ich weiß nicht, wie identisch die sind. Die haben wahrscheinlich alle eine andere Seriennummer, aber die sind ja schon sehr vergleichbar.
Ja, Galileo in der Tat ist insofern auch ein neues Projekt für Europa, weil wir da zum ersten Mal, ja nicht wirklich zum ersten Mal, aber in einem größeren Schiele in eine wirkliche Massenproduktion einsteigen. Wir haben eine vergleichbare Situation heutzutage schon im Telekommunikationsmarkt. Wir wissen ja alle, unsere Fernsehwelt, unsere Kommunikationswelt hängt im großen Maße von den großen Telekom-Satelliten ab, die in der Erdumlaufbahn sich bewegen. Und auch da haben wir natürlich heute schon in gewisser Weise eine Massenproduktion, die natürlich nicht zu vergleich ist mit einer Massenproduktion, eine Million Stück oder sowas. Aber da haben wir durchaus Satellitenserien, wo man sagen kann, da gibt es 10, 15, 20 Exemplare einer bestimmten Serie. So, das ist sehr ähnlich bei Galileo auch. Wobei natürlich nicht alle Galileo-Satelliten im Endeffekt von einer Generation abstammen werden, sondern wir werden höchstwahrscheinlich auch zwei oder drei Generationen da implementieren, wenn wir mal über die gesamte Konstellation von 32 Satelliten sprechen. Das hängt auch einfach damit zusammen, welchen Produktionszeitraum man da braucht. Und auch da wieder die Frage, stehen alle Komponenten immer über die Zeit zur Verfügung? Also da wird es einen gewissen Druck geben, auch, ich sag mal, inkrementelle Entwicklungsschritte drin zu verankern in den einzelnen Satelliten. Nichtsdestotrotz sind wir heute der Meinung, in der Tat bei den Galileo-Satelliten werden wir wahrscheinlich nicht mehr jeden einzelnen Satelliten testen müssen, sondern wir werden wahrscheinlich bei den ersten zwei unsere Simulationen so weit verifizieren und verbessern, dass wir dann mit den Daten, die wir von den späteren Satelliten kriegen werden, uns wahrscheinlich die Tests sparen können. In Anführungszeichen. Aber auch da ist das letzte Wort letztendlich noch nicht gesprochen, weil man muss auch immer bedenken, bei den Tests fließt auch immer Erfahrung aus der Operation aktueller Satelliten ein. Also von jedem Satelliten, den wir bis jetzt in das Weltraum geschossen haben, haben wir auch immer Lehren ziehen können. Diese Lehren nehmen wir natürlich auch immer, um unsere Testverfahren zu verbessern, unsere Simulationsverfahren zu verbessern. Also auch da werden wir sicher aus den ersten Galileo-Satelliten, die dann im Orbit sind, lernen für die Tests, die wir für die späteren machen müssen. Und auch das wird dazu beitragen können, dass wir wahrscheinlich die Tests anzahl verringern können.
Wann ist denn das Test-Center hier aufgebaut worden in Holland, hier im Standort?
Das Test-Center gibt es, seitdem wir die ersten europäischen Weltraummissionen kennen. Das ist hier so in dem Zustand, wie wir es heute kennen, ist es in den 70er Jahren der Grundstein gelegt worden. Vorher gab es auch schon Testanlagen in Europa, die nicht hier in ESTEC waren, sondern die teilweise in Deutschland standen, teilweise in Frankreich waren und auch teilweise hier in Holland.
Aber es gab kein Zentrum und das ist quasi die Aufgabe?
Was wir dann mit Anfang der 70er Jahre begonnen haben, ist für die Aktivitäten der Europäischen Raumfahrt Agentur, also der ESA, die Testaktivitäten hier zu konzentrieren. Insofern müssen wir vielleicht auch ein bisschen die Aussage vom Anfang der Sendung, wo wir gesagt haben, das ist eine einmalige Einrichtung in Europa, müssen wir das insofern ein bisschen korrigieren, dass wir sagen müssen, natürlich die großen Satellitenprimes, die wir heute in Europa kennen, Thales, Astrium, die sich ja im Telekom-Markt auch bewegen, die also für die Telekom Operator Satelliten bauen und in den Orbit bringen. Diese Unternehmen haben eigene Test-Center, die spezifisch darauf fokussiert sind, diese Telekom-Satelliten zu testen.
Aber die müssen dann trotzdem hier noch mal durch?
Nein, die kommen nicht zu uns. Das sind ja auch Satelliten, die nicht durch die ESA beauftragt werden. Die Telekom Operator gehen direkt zu den Satellitenproduzenten hin und vereinbaren mit denen den Bau eines oder einer Serie von Satelliten.
Das heißt, hier landen die ESA-Missionen, also alles das, was auf Zukunft und neue Erkenntnisse ausgerichtet ist, bzw. solche übergeordneten Projekte wie das Navigationssystem Galileo. Womit fängst du dann hier an mit den Tests? Was waren denn dann die Sachen, die hier schon durchgetestet wurden, als erstes nachdem das Testzentrum stand?
Das ist jetzt in der Tat eine Frage, die sehr weit in die Historie reingeht. Und da schwimme ich jetzt selber ein bisschen.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt nicht alles aufzählen.
Was vielleicht für viele Leute noch bekannt ist, ist der Umweltsatellett Envisat, der zurzeit ja auch noch in Operations ist und der vor seinem Start also hier getestet worden ist.
Das ist ein riesen Teil, oder?
Es ist ein sehr grosser. Also einer der größten Satelliten, die die Europäische Raumfahrt Agentur bis heute gebaut hat, war im Prinzip auch ein Wendepunkt dann in der Geschichte der Produktion, weil ab diesem Zeitpunkt hat man sich gesagt, so große Satelliten wollen wir eigentlich nicht mehr bauen. Wir wollen mehr dezidierte, kleinere Missionen haben. Nichtsdestotrotz ein sehr erfolgreicher Satellit, dessen Erfolg auch im Wesentlichen dadurch bedingt ist, dass er hier getestet worden ist oder mit ein Faktor für den Erfolg. Warum? Weil im Laufe einer so langen Satellitenmission, ENVISAT ist ja nun schon fast zehn Jahre im All, gibt es natürlich immer wieder Fehler. Keine Maschine ist fehlerfrei. Und bis jetzt konnten wir alle Fehler zumindest so weit beheben, dass der Satellit weiterhin in Operations ist und seine wissenschaftliche Funktion erfüllen kann. Und das im Wesentlichen auch nur deshalb, weil wir durch die Tests ein intensives Verständnis für diesen Satelliten gewonnen haben. Auf gut Deutsch, wir kennen den Satelliten in- und auswendig. Und wenn wir Daten von dem Satelliten zur Erde bekommen, die zeigen, dass es Anomalien gibt, dann sind wir in der Lage, diese Daten so zu interpretieren, dass wir auch eine Lösung dafür finden für diese Anomalien. Das gelingt natürlich nur, wenn man den Satelliten in- und auswendig kennt. Anderes Beispiel, sie fahren mit ihrem Auto zu einer Werkstatt, die nicht Experte für ihr Auto ist. Sie haben ein etwas schwierigeres Problem daran, die Werkstatt wird zu 99 Prozent nicht wirklich den Fehler beseitigen können, weil sie kein Verständnis hat, weil sie nicht weiß, wo sie nachgucken muss, woher der Fehler eventuell kommen könnte.
Das heißt, der Test macht jetzt nicht nur so die Ampel an mit darf starten, darf nicht starten, sondern es geht eher darum, wirklich auch ein Profil der Eigenschaften zu gewinnen, um zu sehen, wo sind potenzielle Schwachstellen oder wo sind die Toleranzen vielleicht noch ausreichend. Aber wo sind die Sollbruchstellen? Wo sind die potenziellen Fehlerquellen? Was könnte die Ursache sein für ein Fehlverhalten auf Basis eben dieser Testlaufreihe?
Genau so ist das. Um ein anderes Beispiel zu bringen, ein Satellit, der in letzter Zeit im Testcenter hier war, vor zwei, drei Jahren. Der Satellit Hörschel, das Weltraumteleskop, das in einem für die Wissenschaft sehr interessanten Bereich arbeitet. Jeder Satellit hat On-Board-Computer. Also Computer, die das Operation auf dem Computer selber organisieren, steuern und überwachen. Und wie das immer so ist, bei Satelliten, man hat eine Redundanz dieser Systeme. Weil wenn eins ausfällt, will man zumindest noch eine Reserve haben, die das übernehmen kann. Da hatten wir bei Hörschel das Problem, nach dem Start, als wir den Computer hochgefahren haben, gab es einen Kurzschluss und da war der Satellit tot.
Jetzt noch beim Testen?
Nein, im Orbit. Das heißt, der Satellit war, schien zunächst mal für uns verloren zu sein. Wir hatten zwar noch Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten mit ihm, konnten ihn aber nicht mehr operieren. Und aufgrund der Testdaten, die wir hatten, also aufgrund der Erkenntnisse, die wir im Test gefunden hatten, und aufgrund der Daten, die wir dann von oben, von dem Satelliten zurückbekommen und den Experten, die wir hier auf der, die Experten, die den Computer mitgebaut haben, waren wir also in der Lage, die Ursache dieses Kurzschluss herauszufinden. Und die Ursache war als Endes ganz einfach. Das war einfach, da ist offensichtlich ein nicht qualifiziertes Bauteil verbaut worden, was aber letztendlich durch alle Tests nicht wirklich aufgefallen war. Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Diese Fehleranalyse, die wir machen konnten, ermöglichte uns aber für den redundanten Bordcomputer, eine Startsequenz zu erstellen, die es ermöglichte, diesen Computer sicher zu starten, also nicht den gleichen Fehler zu verursachen wie beim ersten Computer.
Was gedroht hätte.
Was gedroht hätte, wenn wir es einfach blind versucht hätten, mit dem zweiten Computer zu starten. Und das hat letztendlich die ganze Mission gerettet. Und wir sehen ja heute, die Mission läuft erfolgreich und der wissenschaftliche Ausput ist größer, als wir jemals gehofft haben. Also man sieht, ein Test des Satelliten dient nicht nur dazu zu sagen, der Satellit ist in Ordnung, wir können ihn starten, sondern er dient auch dazu, Fehler, die auftreten, möglichst effizient und zielorientiert beseitigen zu können.
Jetzt sind das ja alles sehr komplexe Gebilde. Und es sind ja jetzt auch nicht nur Satelliten, die jetzt hier getestet werden, sondern, was ja auch schon erwähnt wurde, auch der ATV ist natürlich hier durchgelaufen. Ist ja auch ein Monstrum, das ist ja noch größer als dieser Envisat, oder?
Also der ist noch mal doppelt so groß wie ein Envisat.
Das heißt, das ATV ist auch das Größte, was jetzt hier getestet wurde?
Wir sagen, für Europa ist das in der Tat das größte Spacecraft, was wir bis jetzt in Europa entwickelt und getestet haben und auch zum Flug gebracht haben. Und zusätzlich noch das weltweit einzige, das sich selbstständig an die ISS heran navigieren kann.
Was muss jetzt so ein Gerät, ein Satellit oder ein Transportraumfahrzeug, was schaut man sich an? Was wird jetzt hier durchlaufen? Womit geht es los?
Wie jeder Satellit durchläuft, eine festgelegte Testsequenz. Er kommt also in das Testcenter hinein und wird dann auf Herz und Nieren geprüft in verschiedenen Testeinrichtungen, die also im Wesentlichen dazu dienen, einmal die Temperaturfestigkeit des Satelliten zu überprüfen, zu überprüfen, dass die Elektronik und die Struktur des Satelliten Vakuumbedingungen überleben kann, dass die Struktur extreme Schallbelastungen überleben kann und dass die Struktur auch Rottelbewegungen, also extremen Beschleunigungsbewegungen, widerstehen kann. Also das sind im Wesentlichen die Kriterien, die hier überprüft werden. Wir haben dazu mehrere Einrichtungen, die sukzessive die Überprüfung der einzelnen Kriterien ermöglicht. Wir haben keine Einrichtung, die die Kriterien insgesamt in einer Einrichtung überprüfen könnte. Also der Test basiert darauf, dass man die verschiedenen Kriterien nacheinander durchläuft und überprüft.
Temperatur und Vakuum, das ist sozusagen Weltraum. Das ist was, was man sozusagen vorfindet, wenn man erst mal gestartet ist. Und Schall und Rütte ist Start.
Das eine ist Rakete und das andere ist Weltall. Um das griffig zu formulieren. Wobei die Belastungen, die der Satellit auf der Rakete erlebt, natürlich nur sehr kurzfristig sind. Ich erinnere daran, im Prinzip die Startzeit einer Rakete ist 2,5 Minuten. Und danach befindet sich der Satellit im Weltraum. Da spielen also Fragen von Akustik, Schall oder Beschleunigung keine große Rolle mehr. Da sind dann Temperaturbelastungen, Vakuumbelastungen, das Kriterium schlecht.
Naja, das heißt, vielleicht gehen wir mal so ein bisschen vom Start her aus. Also das erste, was der Satellit überleben muss, ist der Start. Und das ist im Wesentlichen Vibration. Das kann man sich vorstellen, da explodiert so allerlei Zeug. Das Ding startet los, die ganze Rakete ist in Bewegung und vor allem ist es höllisch laut. Wie laut muss man sich so einen Start vorstellen?
Ja, ein Start ist wirklich laut, um das mal sozusagen im technischen Einheiten ausgedrückt. Der Schalldruck kann bis zu 120 Dezibel hoch werden. Das sind also Schalldrücke, die einen normalen Menschen normalerweise töten. Wenn man einem Schalldruck ungeschützt ausgesetzt ist, dann überlebt man das normalerweise nicht. Das sind schon Dimensionen, die nicht vernachlässigbar sind. Der Vorteil auf der einen Seite ist, dieses Kriterium wirkt nur sehr kurz auf den Satelliten ein. Das ist im Prinzip nur in dem Moment der Fall, wo das Triebwerk gezündet wird oder die Triebwerke zünden, der die Rakete sich im Prinzip noch in unmittelbarer Nähe zum Launchpad, also zum Startpult befindet. Weil da ist der Moment, wo die Schallwellen so reflektiert werden können. Dann von unten an der Rakete, wo die Triebwerke sind, bis oben hin, wo der Satelliten sitzt. Der sitzt ja immer auf der Spitze der Rakete. Also aufgrund der Geometrie können die Schallwellen dann noch bis da oben hin reflektiert werden, sodass sie da eine Wirkung entfalten können oder nicht. Man muss sagen, bis jetzt ist, ich müsste mich sehr täuschen, aber bis jetzt gibt es noch keinen Fall, wo man einen Ausfall eines Satelliten aufgrund eines solchen Schallereignisses hätte zeigen können oder wäre wirklich passiert, nichtsdestotrotz. Die Belastung, die Schallbelastung ist da und man muss überprüfen, weil wenn man keine dieser Belastung standhaft Komponenten hat, dann kann man durchaus einen Fehler erwarten an den Teilen.
Aber das gab es vielleicht schon mal bei einem Test, dass man durchaus…
Ja, natürlich. Der Satellit wird ja nicht nur am Ende getestet, wenn er zusammengeschraubt ist und in seiner fertigen Konfiguration vorliegt, sondern wir testen Teile, Komponenten natürlich auch im Vorfeld. Das gehört zur Materialqualifizierung, zur Komponentenqualifizierung in der Raumfahrt dazu, dass Komponenten oder Materialien, von denen wir denken, dass sie kritisch sind für eine Mission, dass die natürlich im Vorfeld schon auf gewisse Umweltkriterien hingetestet werden. Wieder sind Schallbelastung, Temperaturbelastung, Druckbelastung. Also alle diese Dinge werden auch im Vorfeld einzeln an Komponenten getestet, sodass man also davon ausgehen kann, dass zumindest die Einzelteile diesen Umweltbedingungen widerstehen, die wir da erleben. Nichtsdestotrotz ist natürlich das Ensemble der Komponenten immer noch ein Unterschied gegenüber der Einzelkomponent.
Und ist dann hier auch schon mal was abgesagt im Akustiktest?
Ja, in der Tat, im Akustiktest haben wir hin und wieder auch schon mal Ausfälle, was dann dazu führt, dass Teile entweder ausgetauscht werden oder es auch dazu führt, dass man eine Risikoabwägung macht. Also in unseren Tests gehen wir natürlich teilweise auch in der Belastung über das hinaus, was eigentlich im Weltraum zu erwarten ist. Beziehungsweise beim Start. Das heißt, wir versuchen sozusagen die Margins, also die flexiblen Räume auszutesten, die wir haben. Und wenn man sieht, dass ein Teil sich erst in der Funktion verabschiedet, wenn man eigentlich schon über die Margin hinaus ist, dann kann man natürlich eine Risikoabwertung machen und sagen, gehe ich das Risiko ein? Ich werde wahrscheinlich diese Belastung gar nicht sehen. Oder sage ich, nein, das Risiko ist mir zu groß. Ich muss auf jeden Fall eine andere Lösung finden.
Beziehungsweise das sind dann auch diese Komponenten, die später in einem Fehlfall auch herangezogen werden können.
Genau so ist das. Allerdings muss man ganz, ganz ehrlich sagen, das kommt nur noch in ganz, ganz wenigen Fällen vor, dass wir beim Endtest, also beim Satellitentest, wirklich solche extremen Ausfallereignisse haben. Es passiert und dann wird im Allgemeinen dann auch das Teil ausgetauscht. Aber man muss sagen, unsere Entwicklungen heute sind so gut, dass wir also einen extremen Ausfall eigentlich nicht mehr haben.
Und jetzt desto trotz gibt es hier eine sehr beeindruckende Installation, um diesen Schalltest durchzuführen. Eine riesige Schallkammer, Echo Chamber. Was steckt da drin?
Ja, das ist ganz einfach ausgedrückt, das ist ein Betonklotz, der so ausgelegt ist, dass er möglich selber den Schalldruck aushält, der in seinem Inneren erzeugt wird. Und was sie dann im Prinzip noch brauchen, sind große Hörner, die genug Krach machen, damit sie den Schalldruck im Innenraum erzeugen können.
Also so riesige Alphörner, die da aus der Wand kommen?
Riesige Alphörner, die aus der Wand kommen. Manche Hi-Fi-Fans kennen das vielleicht von zu Hause auch, die haben auch für bestimmte Frequenzen sehr große, hornartige Lautsprecher. Das ist also das Prinzip, was wir da auch benutzen. Mit Pressluft wird der Schall in diesem Horn erzeugt. Das ist jetzt etwas einfacher ausgedrückt. Natürlich ist die Anlage so ausgelegt, dass wir alle Parameter, die wir darin untersuchen, auch beherrschen können. Das heißt, wir können die Tonfrequenz variieren, wir können den Tondruck, den Schallpegel variieren, so wie wir das wollen. Und wir können auch sicherstellen, dass wir auch das Richtige messen in der Anlage. Denn eins ist natürlich, den Schall zu erzeugen. Das Zweite ist natürlich, das auch so zu messen, wie man es erzeugt hat, also dass man sicher sein kann, dass man das auch gemessen hat, was man überprüfen will, was auch schon eine Wissenschaft an sich ist. Und das möchte ich hier auch gerade einflechten, was also auch als Expertise bei unserem Testzentrum sehr gewürdigt wird und wo auch oft externe Einrichtungen kommen, um unsere Leute wiederum für eigene Tests einzukaufen. Weil das ist eine Expertise, die wir hier haben, die schon zumindest interessant ist, auch für viele andere. Es scheint offensichtlich auch eine Kunst zu sein, zu messen und sich sicher zu sein, dass das, was man gemessen hat, auch das ist, was man wirklich messen wollte. Hört sich trivial an, aber...
Generell jetzt oder im Schallbereich?
Generell, generell. Das gilt für alle, die Faktoren, die wir eben ausmessen in unserem Testzentrum. Das ist zum Beispiel auch ein Grund, warum Airbus zu uns gekommen ist mit spezifischen Tests für ihre Flugzeugstrukturen. Weil wir hier nicht nur eine Facility haben, die für Airbus selber nur in wenigen Tests erforderlich ist, deshalb sie selber gar nicht investieren. Vielmehr aber auch, weil wir die Expertise haben, diese Facility so zu benutzen, dass man auch hinterher etwas messen kann und mit diesen Daten dann auch wirklich Schlüsse für die Produktion oder für die Umsetzung im Flugzeug ziehen kann. Also ich denke, jeder, der sich mit sowas auskennt, weiß, dass das keine Trivialität ist.
Beim Rundgang fällt schnell auf, es gibt viele Tore, vor allem für extrem große Tore. Das überrascht schon gar nicht, wenn man dran denkt, dass eben so ein Apparat wie das ATV, ich weiß gar nicht, wie lang ist das Ding?
Das ist durchaus 10 Meter lang und ein Durchmesser von 5 Metern, also in dieser Größenordnung.
Das ist auf jeden Fall schon ein ganz schneller Turm, da muss ja noch irgendwo draufstehen und durch die Gegend gefahren werden. Fast alle Räume haben oben große Kranstrukturen, wie man das so aus der Großindustrie kennt. Das ist ja klar, wenn man die Dinger irgendwo reinheben muss und durch den Raum schleppen muss. Das macht man jetzt nicht mit einem Bollerwagen. Im Falle dieses Akustikraums gibt es dann auch so ein riesiges Schott, wo man das eben reinfährt. Das geht dann zu. Sowohl das von dem inneren Kern als auch das nochmal zum Schallschlucken drum herum gebaute Isoliertank. Und dann gibt es glaube ich sogar noch ein weiteres Tor, weil es dann draußen immer noch was zu hören ist.
Ja, also 120 Dezibel ist in der Tat ein Druck, der nicht einfach zu beherrschen ist. Da kann man in der Tat auch Gebäude mitsprengen, wenn man das richtig anwendet. Und dementsprechend sind halt auch die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen. Das ist in der Tat so, dass die Schallkammer an sich ist selber nochmal isoliert durch eine Isolationskammer von dem weiteren Umgebung. Und in der Tat so, wenn die Tests gefahren werden, dann müssen auch immer noch von den Testern Schutzkleidung und Schutzmaßnahmen getroffen werden, dass man die Tests auch wirklich für Menschen unbeschadet durchführen kann. Nichtsdestotrotz, das hört sich alles etwas dramatisch an, aber es ist natürlich nicht so, dass man mit den Tests die nähere Umgebung gefährden könnte. Also das ist soweit schon alles technisch optimiert und auch unter Kontrolle, dass man da keine Gefährdung Dritter befürchten müsste.
Weltuntergang droht nicht unmittelbar? Nein, nicht direkt. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall schön laut da drin. Und wenn ein Gerät diesen Test unbeschadet überstanden hat, dann kann man sich zumindest schon mal sicher sein, dass dieser eine Aspekt des Staats das Überleben nicht beeinflusst. Die zweite Komponente ist jetzt die Vibration, die jetzt beim Zünden der Raketen auftritt. Wie massiv ist das?
Auch das wieder sehr kurzfristige Belastungen, die aber doch sehr extreme Größenordnungen erreichen können. Also wir reden da schnell von mehreren G, also mehreren äquivalenten Erdbeschleunigung, die auf die Materialien einwirken können. Das ist natürlich eine Belastung, von der man sich verifizieren muss, dass die Materialien das auch wirklich aushalten.
Aber das nur auf sehr, also, ich meine, Vibration geht ja immer hin und her. Also G ist ja jetzt nicht nur in eine Richtung.
Nein, nein, also G ist ja nur eine, ich sag mal, eine Quantifizierung einer Kraft, die auf eine Fläche, also auf ein Objekt einwirken kann. Die Richtung des schweren Feldes der Erde ist natürlich gegeben, aber im Fall von Beschleunigungen kann das natürlich in alle Richtungen auftreten. Das Besondere dabei ist in der Raumfahrt, dass man also nicht nur ein- oder zweidimensionale Beschleunigungen sieht beim Start einer Rakete, sondern dass man im Prinzip in allen Freiheitsgraden Beschleunigung hat, weil das eine wirklich dreidimensionale Bewegung der Rakete ist. Genauso wie man einen schütteln, wenn man ein Glas schüttelt oder eine Box schüttelt, da weiß man auch, man kann die nur horizontal schütteln, man könnte sie auch vertikal schütteln, aber jeder normale Mensch macht eigentlich mehr eine dreidimensionale Schüttelbewegung als eine wirklich lineare oder linearisierte Bewegung. So muss man sich das bei der Rakete auch vorstellen. Die Rakete bewegt sich zuerst mal relativ unkoordiniert, eine kurze Zeit, was also Beschleunigungen im Prinzip in alle Raumrichtungen aufkommen lässt. Und selbst wenn wir in der Flugphase sind, bewegt sich die Struktur in sich selber auch, in Abhängigkeit von Frequenzen, die durch die Motoren erzeugt werden, die durch Kreiselelemente erzeugt werden, die in der Struktur selber sind. Also da gibt es eine Menge Kräfte in der Struktur, die auf die Struktur selber wirkt, die die Struktur selber in Schwingungen versetzen kann. Diese Schwingungen resultieren natürlich letztendlich auch wieder in Beschleunigungen, die auf die Strukturen selber einwirken, zum Beispiel auf den Satelliten, der da auf dem Kopf der Rakete sitzt.
Wie wird das jetzt getestet?
Ansatz ist der, in jedem Flug einer Rakete greifen wir immer diese Information mit Hilfe von Sensoren in der Rakete ab. Wir haben also heutzutage eine relativ gute Vorstellung davon, welche Beschleunigungen innerhalb einer Rakete und außen an der Rakete und auch an der Stelle, wo der Satellit sitzt, herrschen. Jeder Start ist natürlich ein bisschen anders. Wir kriegen also eine Vielfalt von Informationen. Aus diesen Informationen können wir natürlich Spitzenbelastungen rausrechnen, die an bestimmten Zeitpunkten oder an bestimmten Orten in der Rakete herrschen. Diese Spitzenbelastungen wollen wir natürlich versuchen, in unseren Einrichtungen zu simulieren. Das heißt, wenn wir zum Beispiel einen Rotteltisch haben, den wir steuern können, dann versuchen wir da natürlich ein Bewegungsprofil nachzufachen, das wir in einem bestimmten Zeitabschnitt des Aufstiegs der Rakete sehen.
Das heißt, man nimmt wirklich auch Messungen von dem Raketenstart an der Rakete wiederum heran und spielt die quasi wieder ab. Macht man das eigentlich bei dem Akustiktest auch so?
Beim Akustiktest macht man das genauso, weil auch da wird natürlich das eigentliche Schallprofil beim Start selber auch gemessen. Deshalb sind alle Raketen heutzutage mit einer Vielfalt von Sensoren ausgestattet. Das ist also so ein zweieinhalb, drei Minuten Startvorgang, gibt also eine Fülle von Daten heutzutage. Da können Sie alles mit auswerten, was Sie hinterher brauchen. Und natürlich, also einmal haben wir die Realdaten, die wir als Bezugsgröße in den Tests mit einsetzen. Wir fahren aber natürlich auch theoretische Belastungen, also von theoretischen Berechnungen her kommend Spitzenwerte, die man erwarten könnte und versuchen, die dann in Tests zu verifizieren, ob das wirklich das Material aushält oder nicht. Diese Werte können teilweise höher sein, als das, was man in Realität jemals messen wird. Aber das gibt uns halt den nötigen Margin, um sicher sein zu können, dass der Satellit wirklich alles überlebt.
Ja, der Rütteltisch, der Name ist jetzt schon gefallen, scheint so ein bisschen das zentrale Element für diese Vibrationstests zu sein. Eine riesige Apparatur in einem nicht minder riesigen Raum, die in den Boden eingelassen ist. Also woraus besteht dieser Tisch? Also meine Tisch ist ja eigentlich auch schon, das trifft es ja nun sehr eingeschränkt.
Wenn man bedenkt, dass wir Strukturen, also Satelliten testen, die durchaus selber ihre 20 Tonnen, 22 Tonnen wiegen können, dann ist einem schon klar, dass der Tisch selber nicht nur 100 Kilo wiegen kann, sondern der muss ein adäquates Gewicht haben, damit man überhaupt solche Strukturen kontrolliert bewegen kann und das auch beherrschen kann.
Eine Plattform?
Eine Plattform, die natürlich auch selber schon ein Gewicht mitbringt. Im Falle dieses großen Tisches, den wir haben, reden wir da auch schon von 10 Tonnen, was die Plattform selber wiegt. Und diese Plattform wird im Falle der großen Struktur, die wir haben, der großen Testeinrichtungen durch hydropneumatische Pumpen bewegt. Also das ist Öldruck, der die Zylinder bewegt. Und das ist, wie man sich einen Stoßdämpfer vorstellen kann. Der Tisch liegt also auf mehreren Stoßdämpfern. Das sind vier Stoßdämpfer, die unter dem Tisch sind, und vier Stoßdämpfer, die seitlich am Tisch angebracht sind. Mithilfe dieser acht Stoßdämpfer sind wir also in der Lage, diesen Tisch relativ frei im Raum zu bewegen.
Das heißt, wir reden von einer runden Struktur, also diese eigentliche Plattform ist nicht wirklich ein Kreis, idealisiert rund. Genau. Und vier von diesen Stoßdämpfern, oder in diesem Fall mehr so Stoßaustellern eigentlich, sind sozusagen darunter, einfach vertikal angebracht. Und die anderen vier sind......
greifen horizontal von der Seite an den Tisch ran.
Oben sozusagen. Das heißt, wenn einer sich ausfährt, dann gibt er dem Tisch eigentlich eher so eine Drehbewegung, so eine leichte Ankantung.
Genau, das ist nur... Das ganze System wird ja so gefahren, dass nicht nur ein Stoßdämpfer oder Stoßanreger bewegt wird, sondern die werden natürlich in Koordination miteinander gefahren. Und der Mehrwert der Anlage liegt darin, dass man die Stöße, also die Kraft, die durch diese Stöße erzeugt wird, auf dem Tisch, dass man die kontrollieren kann über eine Anlage. Und zwar die kontrolliert man dadurch, dass man genau berechnet, wie stark jeder Stoßdämpfer jetzt den Tisch in einem gegebenen Moment anregen muss. Aus diesen Dingen kann man Bewegungsprofile dann...
Also sie werden nicht irgendwie so zufällig bewegt, weil dann würden sie sich ja unter Umständen auch gegenseitig zerstören. Das wäre sicherlich vorstellbar.
Also ich glaube, man sollte sowieso sagen, in allen Tests wird nichts zufällig bewegt. Der Test lebt davon, dass er genau vorbeplant ist, dass man sich Gedanken darüber macht, was hinterher herauskommen soll und dass man seine Versuchsanordnung so aufbaut, dass man möglichst das auch überprüfen und messen kann, was man hinterher heraus haben will. Also in diesem Sinne auf den Rütteltisch bezogen. Die Bewegungen sind genau vorberechnet. Und wir haben auch bestimmte Erwartungen, welche Kräfte wir dann im Satelliten zum Beispiel messen, als Resultat aus diesen Bewegungen. Und der Test besteht darin, dass man schaut, misst man das wirklich, das erwartete Resultat, oder misst man andere Belastungen? Und das können Sie nur, wenn Sie sicher sind, über das Agents, also das Anstoßende, müssen Sie sicher sein. Denn nur dann können Sie sicher sein, dass das Resultat, was Sie oben messen, und die Differenz zu Ihrer Erwartung durch die Struktur basiert ist, also durch den Satelliten und nicht durch irgendwelche anderen Einflüsse, die Sie vielleicht gar nicht unter Kontrolle haben. Weiß nicht, ob ich da so klar jetzt war, aber...
Nee, nee, ich finde das schon nachvollziehbar. Ich überlegte jetzt nur gerade, wir hatten ja vorhin schon diesen Punkt, dass Messen an sich eine Kunst ist. Ich denke, das wird jetzt hier relativ klar. Ich frage mich jetzt nur gerade, was eigentlich die Raumfahrzeuge führende, oder was auch immer dort getestet wird, für eine Eigenschaft im Wesentlichen mitbringen müssen, um so einem Gerüttel auch widerstehen zu können. Also das ist ja sicherlich auf der einen Seite eine gewisse Stabilität. Aber da will man das eben jetzt auch von Häusern, die auf Erdbeben flexibel regieren sollen, ja kennt in gewisser Hinsicht auch eine flexible Bauweise.
Ja, in der Tat ist natürlich das Design, das Strukturdesign angepasst an die Belastungen, die man erwartet. Und in der Tat haben wir da auch eine Kombination zwischen hochfesten Elementen und flexiblen Elementen, um mit den Belastungen umzugehen. Auch wenn man sich einen Sateliten mal versucht, vorzustellen, der also ein klassischer Satelit hat einen relativ kompakten Kern. Und dann gibt es das, was viele Leute dann als Segel kennen, das sind also diese Solar Panels, die außen dran stehen. Man sieht also schon, man ist vor dem Problem, dass man mit flexiblen Strukturen arbeiten muss und gleichzeitig hochfeste Strukturen hat, die den Satelitenkern, die die Propulsion, also den Antriebseinheit umfassen, die die Steuerung des Sateliten umfassen. Diese Dinge muss man also miteinander kombinieren. Und da gibt es in der Tat bautechnische Entwicklungen, die es ermöglichen, sowas wirklich umzusetzen.
Dieser Rüttel-Tisch ist ja ein Riesentrum, also nicht nur die 10 Tonnen dieser Plattform, sondern auch die Konstruktion darunter. Wie verhindert man denn, dass die Vibrationen jetzt, die entstehen ja da, wie verhindert man, dass man sich nicht in eine ganze Halle dabei wegrüttelt? Kann ja auch passieren.
Da helfen vielleicht ein bisschen, sich an die letzten Bilder des Erdbebens aus Japan zu erinnern, wo man im Fernsehen auch Bilder sehen konnte, wo gezeigt wurde, wie ganze Häuser auf Sprungfedern standen. Da wurden also auch Fundamente gezeigt, die im Prinzip auf Federn standen, um die Vibrationen der Erde zu entkoppeln, sodass die Häuser sich möglichst nicht in der gleichen zerstörerischen Frequenz bewegen wie die Erdbewegungen. Das gleiche Prinzip wendet man auch bei solchen sich bewegenden Strukturen in Häusern an. Das heißt, man entkoppelt die Bewegung dieser Strukturen von der Bewegung des Hauses. Das einfachste Prinzip, was auch heute immer noch gilt, ist, man setzt es auf Federn.
Das heißt, so ist das auch hier?
So ist das auch hier, genau. Das ganze Fundament dieser Einrichtung, dieses Rotteltisches, steht also auf Federn, die die Bewegung dieser Einrichtung von dem Haus entkoppeln.
Und das funktioniert auch so, dass man dann gar nichts mehr merkt oder bleibt da doch noch was über?
Jeder, der Auto fährt, weiß natürlich, dass eine Federung nicht völlig alle, ich sag mal, Stöße des Untergrundes wegnehmen kann. Wir wissen, es gibt gute Federungen, da merkt man nur noch ganz wenig. Es gibt schlechte Federungen, da fühlt man sich mehr wie auf der Achterbahn. Da geht es also rauf und runter und man merkt es im Rücken. Aber selbst die beste Federung, wie wir uns alle erinnern, kann nicht verhindern, dass nicht doch gewisse Stöße durchkommen. So ist das natürlich bei solchen Anlagen hier auch. Diese Federungen entkoppeln nicht total von zwei Elemente voneinander. Aber das ist auch gar nicht Ziel der Sache. Der Ziel der Sache ist, man möchte so weit entkoppeln, dass diese Bewegung nicht zerstörerisch zum Beispiel auf die Hausstruktur wirkt. Das gilt ja auch bei Gebäuden in Erdbebengebieten. Denn auch gefederte Gebäude bewegen sich, nur mit einer Frequenz, die das Gebäude nicht mehr zerstört. Das ist ja das ultimative Ziel, das man hat.
Das heißt, wenn jetzt hier ein Rotteltest gefahren wird, dann merkt man das auch in der Umgebung?
Dann weiß jeder in dem Gebäude, da wird ein Rotteltest gefahren. Auch ohne, dass es irgendwelche Sirenen gibt.
Gut, aber man muss nicht gleich alle Gläser festhalten oder so? Wie lange wird da jetzt so gerüttelt an so einem Apparat?
Auch das ist sehr, sehr kurzfristig, wie gesagt, weil die meisten Schwingungsbelastungen während des Starts auftreten. Das heißt, wir unterhalten uns in einem Zeitraum von zweieinhalb, drei Minuten. Da simulieren wir im Wesentlichen auch nur die Spitzenwerte. Das heißt, die Rottelbewegungen befinden sich im Bereich wenige Millisekunden bis eine Minute maximal. Also längerfristig wird nicht agitiert, wie wir sagen, also angeregt auf der Plattform. Ist auch nicht notwendig. Man macht durchaus auf Komponentenlevel, macht man im Vorfeld längerfristige Rotteltests. Dass man Komponenten durchaus mal eine Rotteldauer von einer Stunde oder auch länger aussetzt, um sozusagen an die Schmerzgrenze der Komponenten ranzugehen und zu beurteilen, wo liegt denn überhaupt die Grenze dessen?
Aber für die Komponenten braucht man jetzt nicht diesen 10-Tonnen-Tisch.
Nein, das ist ja auch der Grund, warum man es auf Komponentenlevel macht. Diese Tests sind dann natürlich wesentlich preiswerter als das, was man mit dem ganzen Satelliten macht. Das heißt, die Philosophie, die dahinter ist, ist, wenn man einen Satelliten zusammenschraubt, ist man sich vor dem Zusammenschrauben auf jeden Fall sicher schon mal, dass jede einzelne Komponente die Kriterien überleben kann, die an den Satelliten gestellt werden, meistens noch mit einer wesentlichen Sicherheitsmargin dabei.
Das heißt, im Prinzip testet man am Schluss eigentlich nur noch die Gesamtstruktur?
Genau so ist das.
Aber es gibt jetzt auch noch Rütteltests in anderen Größenordnungen hier?
Ja, genau. Diese Einrichtung ist ein Rütteltest, wo wir im Prinzip alle Anregungsbewegungen auf einer Einheit testen können. Wir haben auch andere Einheiten, wo wir lineare Anregungsbewegungen mehr austesten, also in horizontalem oder in der vertikalen Richtung, weil es durchaus Missionen gibt, wo der gleichzeitige Test aller Anregungsvektoren nicht notwendig ist. Auch das wiederum bedeutet, man kann den Test preiswerter machen, weil die Anlage liegt irgendwo auch ein bisschen auf der Hand. Je größer die Anlage, umso größer sind im Allgemeinen auch die Betriebskosten dieser Anlage. Wir versuchen natürlich heute, unsere Missionen kostengünstig umzusetzen. Also versuchen wir da auch eine gewisse Ökonomie reinzubringen in das Testen.
Die vorhin angesprochenen Kooperationen mit Airbus finden unter anderem auch mit diesem Rütteltisch statt.
Genau, Airbus ist natürlich insbesondere an diesen Rüttelversuchen interessiert. Warum? Weil es da ja auch um die Beschleunigungsbelastung in den Strukturen geht. Zum Beispiel bei der Landung oder im Fall von Crash-Landungen, genauso wie man das im Auto eben auch kennt.
Aber würde man nicht erwarten, dass jetzt Airbus auch entsprechende Test-Facilities hat für ihre Flugzeuge?
Ja, natürlich haben die selber Facilities. Aber ich sagte ja schon mal, es gibt Dinge, die sind sehr spezifisch und die bedürfen eines spezifischen Fachwissens. Und oftmals ist das Fachwissen wichtiger als die Anlage. Und unsere Experten haben halt seit über 30 Jahren, seitdem wir das hier machen in ESTEC, haben die Erfahrung mit Extremschüttel-Tests, um das mal so zu sagen. Und das ist eine Expertise, die finden sie nicht mehr. Zweimal in Europa. Und das sind einfach Testszenarien, die man vielleicht früher in der Luftfahrt nicht so beachtet hat, die auch eventuell nicht so eine große Rolle gespielt haben. Aber die heutzutage bei modernen Flugzeugen, die ja auch immer größer werden und immer leistungsfähiger werden, und wo die Strukturen von ihrem spezifischen Gewicht her auch immer leichter werden, wo also Strukturbelastungsfragen immer größere Rolle spielen, da fängt das langsam an, Interesse in der Luftfahrt zu finden. Und für Unternehmen, die ja auch sehen müssen, dass sie ökonomisch arbeiten, ist es natürlich erst mal einfacher, auf vorhandene Expertise zurückzugreifen und zu sehen, was für einen Vorteil habe ich überhaupt daraus, wenn ich solche Tests mache. Anstatt erst mal selber zu investieren und dann festzustellen, das ist eigentlich gar nicht so von Interesse, das brauche ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Und mein ganzes Flugzeug kriegt man da jetzt nicht drauf?
Nee, dafür ist die Anlage dann nicht ausgerichtet. Ist aber oftmals auch gar nicht gefragt. Weil wie gesagt, was wir hier für Airbus machen, sind mehr Evaluierungstests, die also darauf abzielen, überhaupt erst mal zu sehen, macht es Sinn, ein bestimmtes Testverfahren einzusetzen. Bringt uns das Vorteile gegenüber dem, was man vorher gemacht hat.
So, das sind jetzt sozusagen die wesentlichen Komponenten, um den Start zu simulieren. Wenn also ein Raumfahrzeug Schall- und Rütteltest erfolgreich bestanden hat, also es geht natürlich jetzt nicht zwangsläufigerweise in dieser Reihenfolge, aber ich denke, um das jetzt sozusagen nachzuvollziehen, was die realen Auswirkungen sind auf einen Satelliten und andere Raumfahrzeuge, passt die Reihenfolge. Jetzt ist das Ding also ausgesetzt und geht in seinen Orbit, wo auch immer der sein mag, oder vielleicht auch auf eine andere Fernroute. Jetzt kommt das Weltall und das ist ja auch jetzt nicht so harmonisch. Temperatur haben wir schon mehrfach angesprochen. Entweder man blickt direkt auf die Sonne, da ist es dann furchtbar heiß, oder man ist halt hinter einem Planeten oder auf der Rückseite von irgendwas, dann ist es gleich furchtbar kalt. Wie kann man denn sowas simulieren?
Ja, da kommen jetzt unsere besonders großen Anlagen zum Einsatz. Die nennen wir Weltraumsimulatoren. Und wir haben hier in ESTEC die größte Anlage weltweit dazu, wo wir also in der Lage sind, sowohl Temperaturbedingungen, wie auch Vakuumbedingungen, wie auch Sonnenbestrahlungsbedingungen zu simulieren. Und diese Anlage ist also entsprechend der europäischen Philosophie darauf ausgelegt, dass wir darin Satelliten testen können, die maximal von einer Ariane 5 transportiert werden können. Das heißt, wir reden also von Satelliten bis in die größten Klasse, 20 Tonnen. ATV 20 Tonnen, zwar kein Satellit, aber ein Spacecraft, das von Ariane 5 transportiert werden kann. Und bis zu dieser Größenordnung können wir also in dieser Kammer testen. Man muss sich das als großen Topf vorstellen.
Ist auch aus Metall, ne?
Ist auch aus Metall, in der Tat. Dieser Topf kann also im Inneren evakuiert werden. Das heißt, wir können die Luft, die im Inneren ist, abpumpen.
Gekriegt das Wort evakuieren, weil er seinen ursprünglichen Sinn hat?
Ja, da kriegt es in der Tat einen ursprünglichen Sinn.
Ein Vakuum einleiten, ja.
Wir können also die Luft abpumpen und gleichzeitig können wir die Temperatur im Innenraum kontrollieren. Also über flüssiges Helium sind wir also in der Lage, die Anlage bis zu minus 170 Grad runter zu kühlen. Es ist also sehr kalt.
Ist das schon kälter als das, was man jetzt so üblicherweise vorfindet? Ich meine, wie kalt wird es denn real so im Orbit?
Ja, das ist auch stark abhängig davon, was sie für eine Mission haben und wo sie letztendlich hinfliegen. Also gucken wir uns mal die ISS an. Da haben wir kalte Temperaturen um die minus 100 Grad. Wenn wir also im Erdschatten uns befinden, gut, wenn wir dann wieder in den beschiedenen Orbit hineinkommen, wird es natürlich wieder relativ warm und dann kann es schnell auch 100 Grad plus oder noch mehr werden. Nur haben wir ja das Problem, es ist nicht nur, dass der Orbit eine Rolle spielt, sondern auch die Frage, sonnenzugewandte Seite des Satelliten und sonnenabgewandte Seite. Sie haben also schon allein auf dem Satelliten an sich ein extremes Temperaturprofil. Weil klar, von der anderen Seite ist nichts, was den Satelliten heizen könnte. Es ist nicht so wie auf der Erde, wo sie eine Atmosphäre haben, die ihnen rundum Wohlfühlwärme vermittelt, sondern da oben gibt es halt nichts, was auf der anderen Seite Wärme vermitteln könnte. Insofern haben sie extremste Temperaturunterschiede. Wenn wir Missionen haben wie Herschel oder Planck oder auch Deep Space Missionen, wo wir zu anderen Planeten hinfliegen, da kommen wir schnell in Temperaturbereiche rein, die nah an den absoluten Nullpunkt rangehen.
Also Null Kelvin, das sind dann Minus?
Ja, gut. Wir haben natürlich nicht Null Kelvin im Weltraum, weil wir haben ja auch immer noch die Hintergrundstrahlung, die Weltraumhintergrundstrahlung in der Größenordnung 4, 5 Kelvin oder was immer dieses neue Experiment da oben uns in Zukunft sagen wird. Also wir sind schon über dem absoluten Nullpunkt, aber wir reden schnell über 20, 30 Kelvin, die wir durchaus sehen können.
Das ist wiederum jetzt eine Kälte, die man nicht simuliert bekommt.
Das ist eine Kälte, die wir hier, die könnten wir simulieren. Der Einsatz ist der, ich sag mal der Ressourceneinsatz, um das zu tun, um eine Anlage auf diese Temperaturen, ist allerdings so groß, dass wir sagen, wir unsere Erfahrungen zeigen. Der Unterschied zwischen, ich sag mal, 100 Kelvin und 20 Kelvin macht keinen Effekt auf die Struktur oder auf die Elektronik aus. Also anders ausgedrückt, einfach ausgedrückt, die Elektronik, die 100 Kelvin überlebt, überlebt auch 20 Kelvin. Es wird erst ein Unterschied, wenn sie zu ganz extremen tiefen Temperaturen gehen, wo sie dann auch wieder Materialphasen, Übergänge und das alles haben. Aber ich sag mal, in dem Bereich, wo wir heutzutage uns mit Spacecraft bewegen, hat das keinen entscheidenden Faktor. Und da reicht das, wenn sie bei 150 Kelvin testen, dann haben sie eine signifikante Aussage, die es ihnen erlaubt, zu sagen, diese Spacecraft überlebt den freien Weltraum.
Also 100 Kelvin minus 173 Celsius, das ist das, was man da erzielen kann.
Da brauchen wir also ungefähr zwei Tage zu, bis wir bei dieser Temperatur sind.
Wirklich?
Ich meine, Sie müssen bedenken, die Umgebung ist halt schon noch warm. Und so gut Sie auch isolieren mögen, Sie kühlen immer gegen eine doch dann recht hohe Umgebungstemperatur an. Die Massenträgheit im System bedeutet schon, dass Sie einige Zeit konstant kühlen müssen, um auf eine bestimmte Temperatur runterkommen zu können.
Aber die Hitze wird dort auch simuliert.
Und wir können natürlich dann auch wieder Temperatur rauffahren. Da haben wir einmal in der Anlage selber sogenannte Temperatur-Light-Folien drin, die also Hitze in das System wieder abgeben können. Und die zweite Art, wie wir Temperatur simulieren, ist, dass wir eine Sonnensimulation in der Anlage haben. Das heißt, wir bestrahlen die Satelliten mit einem sonnenlicht-äquivalenten System. Auch in der Sonnenstrahlung, keine Weisheit, haben wir Infrarotstrahlung, also Strahlung, die aufheizt, die Temperatur transportiert. Und dieses Infrarotlicht beeinflusst natürlich auch die Oberfläche des Satelliten, sodass wir also über die Einstrahlung durch die Sonnensimulation auch Oberflächentemperaturen auf dem Satelliten, die der Satellit im Orbit sieht, durchaus simulieren können. Praktisch ausgedrückt, wenn wir die Situation haben, die wir im Orbit haben, wir haben eine sonnenzugewandte Seite des Satelliten und eine sonnenabgewandte Seite. Und auf der sonnenabgewandten Seite haben wir schnell mal 150 Kelvin. Dann fahren wir die Anlage auf 150 Kelvin runter und bestrahlen dann mit der Sonnensimulation von einer Seite den Satelliten und kriegen so auf der sonnenzugewandten Seite des Satelliten durchaus Temperaturen von 100, 120 Grad plus.
Wo kriegt man denn jetzt so schnell eine Sonne her?
Manche Leute simulieren andere Dinge, wir simulieren die Sonne. Wir sollten vielleicht mal überlegen, ob wir das verkaufen können in manchen Regionen dieser Welt. Nein, Scherz beiseite. Sonnensimulation heißt natürlich, man versucht im Wesentlichen, die Qualität der Sonnenstrahlung im sichtbaren Bereich und im Infrarotbereich zu simulieren. Was wir natürlich nicht ohne weiteres simulieren können, sind Strahlung in anderen elektromagnetischen Bereichen, Vakuum-UV, Röntgenstrahlung. Gut, dafür ist die Quelle nicht ausgelegt.
Also es wird jetzt keine Kernfusion betrieben?
Nein, sondern wir nehmen handelsübliche Lichtquellen. In diesem Falle ist es eine Xenon-Lichtquelle, die wir benutzen. Die kann also einen bestimmten Spektralbereich des Sonnenlichtes simulieren. Der aber extrem wichtig ist für das Temperaturverhalten des Satelliten. Nämlich der Infrarotbereich, der extrem die Oberfläche beeinflusst und der extrem die Oberfläche aufheizen kann. Da liegt der Fokus in der Anlage drauf. Was wir da an Leistungen zu bringen ist, das entspricht für die Fläche des Satelliten betrachtet, können wir da bis zu 20-fach in der Sonnenleistung hochgehen, wenn wir also dieses Temperaturprofil austesten. Also eine Hitze, die 20-mal stärker ist als das, was ein Satellit normalerweise auf einer erdnahen Umlaufbahn von der Sonne sieht.
Das heißt, man kann auch eine Laufbahn, die weit weg von der Erde und sehr viel näher an der Sonne ist, simulieren.
Genau, wenn sie wesentlich näher an die Sonne gehen, gehen sie zum Beispiel bis zum Merkow.
Das ist wie Venus Express oder so etwas.
Ja, aber wir wollen ja zum Beispiel auch zu Merkow fliehen, mit Pepi Colombo. Da haben sie also ungefähr das 20-fache der Sonnenstrahlung, die wir hier auf der Erde sehen. Und das ist natürlich eine Extrembelastung für den Satelliten. Wo das als erstes auftritt, ist natürlich bei den Solarzellen. Sie wissen selber, Solarzellen haben großes Problem der Degradation, auch hier auf der Sonne. Wenn Sie Solarzellen lange der Sonnenstrahlung aussetzen, dann nimmt die Leistung der Solarzellen ab. Jetzt sind wir da oben in einem Bereich, wo wir sowieso schon das 20-fache dessen sehen, was wir auf der Erde sehen. Da hatten wir extreme Probleme, Materialien zu bekommen und Solarzellen zu entwickeln, die diese Strahlung lang genug aushalten. Immerhin reden wir da von einer Missionsdauer von zwei, drei Jahren um den Merkur herum. Das sind also alles Dinge, die wir dann auch hier in der Anlage austesten können. Was wir auch zurzeit machen.
Jetzt schon für den BepiColombo?
Jetzt schon für den BepiColombo.
Der 2014 startet, glaube ich, wenn es klappt. Ich weiß es nicht so genau.
Das zählt bei uns zu den sogenannten wissenschaftlichen Missionen. Wissenschaftliche Missionen sind natürlich immer sehr ambitioniert. Das heißt, wir wollen da natürlich zum Erkenntnisgewinn der Wissenschaft beitragen. Das heißt, sie gehen mit allem, was sie da machen, technologisch, vom wissenschaftlichen Ansatz her, an das Frontend dessen, was heute State of the Art ist, also was heute en vogue ist. Und das bedeutet natürlich schon, sie gehen auch ein Risiko ein. Sie wissen im Vorfeld, wenn sie ein Missionsdesign machen, nicht zu 100 Prozent, ob sie das wirklich alles technologisch umsetzen können. Deshalb ist teilweise auch sehr viel Lied, also Entwicklungszeit dabei.
Wie kriegt man denn jetzt diese Sonnenstrahlung da rein in den Kochtopf?
Ja, sie müssen lapidar ausgedrückt, sie müssen quasi eine Glühlampe in den Kochtopf halten. Und es ist natürlich klar, der Kochtopf ist also ohne Luft, ist evakuiert. Sie kriegen also nicht ganz so einfach den Deckel auf, um die Lampe da rein zu halten. Das heißt, sie müssen vorher schon einen Interface schaffen, dass sie die Lampe auch wirklich da andocken können. Auf gut Deutsch, die Lampe ist Teil ihres Topfes. Und wie das immer so ist, bei Lampen, Lampen neigen dazu, ein nicht homogenes Strahlenfeld zu erzeugen. Das heißt, sie setzen also optische Möglichkeiten ein, um ihr Strahlenfeld möglichst homogen zu machen. Weil eines der Beautys des Weltraums ist ja, dass sie ihr Spacecraft, bezogen auf den Spacecraft, ein homogenes Strahlenfeld da oben sieht. Der Solarflügel kriegt jetzt nicht mehr Strahlung ab als der Kern des Satelliten. Während in einer Anlage, wo sie mit einem fokussierten Lichtstrahl drauf strahlen, laufen sie natürlich schnell die Gefahr, dass der Kern des Satelliten mehr Strahlung sieht als die Peripherie. Das wollen sie natürlich verhindern. Also haben wir ein optisches System in der Kammer installiert, die es uns ermöglicht in einem definierten Bereich, der meistens oder der immer so groß ist, wie der Satellit selber auch groß ist, dass wir also in diesem definierten Bereich ein homogenes Strahlenfeld erzeugen können und somit eine repräsentative Simulation zum Weltraum haben.
Das heißt, es läuft über so ein Spiegelverteilungssystem.
Das ist ein Spiegelsystem. Das Spiegel selber ist aus vielen Spiegelwaben aufgebaut, die man also justieren kann und so den Fokus des Strahls verändern kann.
Also es ist keine fixe Installation, sondern es ist auch noch variabel. Man kann es sozusagen anpassen auf das Objekt.
Genau, das geschieht allerdings nicht automatisch, sondern das muss von Hand passieren. Das heißt, da krabbeln Leute in die Anlage rein und justieren die Spiegel von Hand. Das dauert dann auch mal schnell gerne zwei Monate, bis man die dann neu justiert hat. Also das ist also nicht so, dass man da mal gerade so auch jetzt mache ich heute mal ein bisschen engeren Strahl, sondern man überlegt sich vorher schon sehr, sehr genau, was man untersuchen wird und daraufhin wird die Anlage dann optimiert.
Das heißt, mit so einem Test ist der LSS auch teilweise über Monate hin ausgelastet?
Ja.
Das ist gar nicht so die Kapazität, dass man da jetzt jeden Tag was anderes reinfahren könnte oder so?
Also wir sagen, um mal ein, zwei Hausnummern zu geben, das Test Centre insgesamt kann im Jahr drei bis vier Vollsystemtests fahren. Das heißt auf gut Deutsch, wir können drei bis vier Satelliten durchschleusen. Wo wir dann sagen können, die sind qualifiziert, getestet worden. Der LSS selber ist in der Tat ein sehr großer Teststand und die normale Testzeit in so einem Stand ist mindestens ein bis anderthalb Monate, wobei die reine Testzeit dann in der Größenordnung von ein bis zwei Wochen liegt. Das andere ist also Vorbereitung, Vorbereitung des Satelliten, Einsetzen des Satelliten in den Teststand, Vorbereitung des Teststandes, also Anfahren des Teststandes und bis dann sozusagen die Standardkonditionen hergestellt sind in diesem Gerät, dann hat man so ein, zwei Wochen reine Testzeit und dann wird das Ganze wieder abgeschaltet, abbauen und so weiter. Da reden wir also in der Größenordnung ein bis anderthalb Monate für einen Standardtest. Jetzt kommt es aber natürlich auf die Missionen an. Manche Missionen haben sehr extensive Strahlenrequirements, zum Beispiel. Da kann es gut und gerne sein, dass wir ein Satellit mal vier Monate lang bestrahlen, um auf eine vergleichbare Strahlenleistung zu kommen, wie der Satellit dann wirklich im Obed sieht.
Um sozusagen so eine Dauerbelastung zu machen. Aber man macht das ja auch immer alles schon so auf dem, genau dem Satelliten, der dann später auch fliegt. Es wird jetzt nicht auf der Kopie gearbeitet. Der verbraucht sich dadurch ja auch schon so ein bisschen.
Der ist, also grundsätzlich gilt, jeder Satellit, der fliegt, ist getestet worden in der Anlage. Natürlich kennen wir auch sogenannte Quality Models oder Engineering Models. Das sind also Vorstufen des Satelliten. Und teilweise werden Fragestellungen auch schon an diesen Teilen getestet. Nichtsdestotrotz, jeder Satellit, der fliegt, wird in der Anlage getestet.
Das heißt, zu der eigentlichen Belastung durch den Flug kommt eigentlich auch immer noch die Belastung durch den Test mit dazu, die man eigentlich auch gleich noch mit einrechnen muss?
Genau, genau.
Jetzt gibt es nicht nur diesen großen, also es gibt den Large-Raumsimulator, es gibt auch noch einen kleinen.
Wir haben auch kleinere, zwei kleinere. Wir haben heute einen noch gesehen. Bei unserem kurzen Rundgang, es gibt noch eine etwas kleinere Version.
Für das Weltall zwischendurch?
Für das Weltall zwischendurch, für den schnellen Weltraumspaziergang, um das mal so zu sagen. Nein, um auf das Thema zurückzukommen. Die kleineren Anlagen unterscheiden sich von der großen im Wesentlichen dadurch, natürlich, dass sie kleiner sind, aber dass sie keine Strahlenquelle haben. Das heißt, dort können wir keine Bestrahlung simulieren. Dort simulieren wir immer nur thermische Belastungen. Und da spielen die kleinen Anlagen schon ihren Vorteil gegenüber der größeren Anlage aus. Warum? Weil erstens der Ressourceneinsatz, um die Anlage anzufahren und wieder abzufahren, natürlich wesentlich geringer ist als bei der großen Anlage. Also ich sagte schon, die große Anlage wird mit Helium gekühlt. Und bei den Temperaturen, die wir erreichen müssen, müssen wir auch mit Helium kühlen. Die kleine Anlage verbraucht für einen Test ungefähr nur ein Drittel des Heliums, die die große Anlage braucht. Und wenn Sie bedenken, dass das Helium Sie bei einem Test der großen Anlage in der Größenordnung eine Million Euro kostet für einen Test und Sie dann sowas auch mit 300.000 Euro machen könnten, dann liegt natürlich auf der Hand, warum man auch gerne in kleinere Anlagen geht, wenn man dann nicht unbedingt eine Strahlenbelastung dieses Satelliten ausmessen muss. Und zum Beispiel im Falle von Galileo, wo der Orbit sehr bekannt ist, wo man auch aus älteren Satelliten weiß, wie die thermische Belastung in diesem Orbit sein wird, auch von der Strahlenbelastung her, kann man natürlich dort schon vieles in der Simulation vorher entscheiden. Und man muss eigentlich nur eine thermische Verifizierung durchführen im Test hinterher. Und diesen Weg wird man auch bei Galileo wählen. Also man wird den Galileo nicht mehr nochmal mit einer Simulationssonne bestrahlen, weil die Simulationen, die man vorher gemacht hat, mit den Erfahrungswerten, die man von alten Satelliten hat, sind erlauben, eine Entscheidung treffen zu können, die Struktur überlebt oder nicht überlebt. Also da muss ich nicht mehr in die große Kammer gehen und diesen Test aussetzen. Und deshalb geht man dann halt in die kleinere Kammer, was preiswerter ist, was schneller ist und was für diesen Einsatz völlig ausreichend ist.
Strahlen, also Strahlen gibt es ja viele. Was ist denn mit elektromagnetischen Einflüssen, die finden ja nun auch noch kräftig statt? Wird das in diesem LSS auch mit abgedeckt?
In der Tat, wie ich eben schon sagte, die Strahlung ist im Prinzip auf die sichtbare Strahlung plus bestimmte Qualitäten des Infrarotbereiches beschränkt, die wir da simulieren können. Alles andere, Röntgenstrahlung, Vakuum-UV, harte Röntgenstrahlung, Partikelstrahlung, können wir natürlich nicht in dieser Anlage simulieren. Und es gibt auch weltweit keine Anlage, wo man einen Satelliten dem exponieren könnte. Dabei hilft man sich im Prinzip damit, dass man Komponenten, von denen man weiß, dass sie Strahlen empfindlich dafür sind, also zum Beispiel elektronische Komponenten, Computer, Prozessoren, sind erheblich anfällig gegen weiche Röntgenstrahlung, gegen Partikelstrahlung. Diese Sachen können vielerlei Effekte in Prozessoren, in anderen elektrischen Bauteilen auslösen. Und da haben wir ja heutzutage auch sogenannte strahlengehärtete Designs. Da gibt es also spezielle Prozessoren, die sind schon vom Design her, ich sag mal, fehlertoleranter gegenüber Strahlung als die, die wir in unseren Bürorechnen oder in unseren Privatrechnen haben. Und sowas wird immer nur auf Prozessor- oder Bausteinlevel geprüft. Das heißt, da gehe ich mit dem kleinen Prozessor in eine Anlage rein, die mir Röntgenstrahlung produziert oder in einen Schwer-Ionen-Beschleuniger, wo ich Partikelstrahlung haben kann und teste dann, ob das Teil überlebt oder nicht.
Aber solche Facilities gibt es hier auch?
Nein, sowas haben wir hier nicht. Also wenn man sich zum Beispiel mal Schwer-Ionen-Beschleuniger ansieht, da sind ja auch sehr große Anlagen, die sehr viel Geld kosten. Also eine sehr große Anlage ist z.B. CERN in der Schweiz, also auch eine europäische Gemeinschaftsaufgabe. Aber es gibt ja auch in Deutschland noch andere Beschleuniger, desi z.B. in Hamburg. Wir gehen dann mit unseren Testsansprüchen dorthin und testen unsere Materialien dort. Wir kaufen uns also Beamzeit dort ein und gehen dann dahin und testen. Und für die verschiedenen Strahlenqualitäten, die wir testen wollen, gehen wir halt zu den verschiedenen Anlagen in Europa hin, um das dann dort jeweils auszutesten.
Aber es gab da jetzt beim Rundgang noch so einen Raum, der sich mit Elektromagnetismus beschäftigt.
Ja, was sie natürlich auch immer austesten müssen, ist, auf einem Satelliten haben sie natürlich eine Vielfalt von elektrischen Anlagen. Und jede elektrische Anlage erzeugt natürlich für sich selber auch elektromagnetische Strahlung. Und sie wollen natürlich sicher sein, dass das elektromagnetische Strahlenumfeld, das der Satellit aus sich selber ausgeneriert, nicht seine Operations behindert. Also die Funktionstüchtigkeit von sich selber behindert. Das sind die sogenannten elektromagnetischen Kompatibilitätstests, die man zum Beispiel auch bei einem Fernseher macht. Sie wollen ja nicht, dass die Strahlung, die die elektrischen Komponenten erzeugen, ihr Bild beeinflusst zum Beispiel. Genauso was sie da machen, machen sie auch bei einem Satelliten. Beim Satelliten ist es halt ein bisschen komplexer, weil der Satellit groß ist und relativ viel Energie hat, auch dementsprechend Strahlungsfelder erzeugen kann. Und in solchen Kammern messen sie halt erst mal, welches elektromagnetische Strahlenfeld der Satellit überhaupt erzeugt. Und zweitens hat das irgendeinen Einfluss auf das Funktionieren dieses Satelliten. Sie haben ja zum Beispiel auch Payload da drauf, die zum Beispiel elektromagnetische Strahlung auf dem Jupiter vermessen will oder irgendwo im Weltraum. So wollen sie natürlich nicht, dass dieses Gerät nur die Strahlung detektiert, die der Satellit selber erzeugt, sondern möglichst die, die sie eigentlich vermessen wollen. Also müssen sie sich vorher Gedanken darüber machen und ein Gefühl dafür bekommen, was ist überhaupt das Strahlungumfeld, das der Satellit selber generiert.
So, dass man es im besten Fall ignoriert, also gar nicht mitmisst oder im schlimmsten Fall rausrechnen kann oder so etwas. Also das sind auch Tests, die hier gemacht werden.
Ja, das machen sie mit jedem Satelliten auch und das passiert auch in dieser Testanlage.
Wie lange verbleibt dann jetzt hier so ein ATV zum Beispiel? Wie lange wurde der hier durchgenudelt, bis der wirklich seinen Stempel bekommen hat und gesagt hat, du darfst uns alle?
Also das ist eine schwierig zu beantwortende Frage, weil wir bis jetzt keine Routinesatelliten darin haben. Sprich, wie ich am Anfang schon mal gesagt habe, wir behandeln ja immer Prototypen und jeder Satellit hat unterschiedliche Anforderungen. Und es gibt Satelliten, die gehen sehr schnell durch. Weil die Anforderungen vom Umfeld her, vom Weltraumumfeld nicht so dominant sind, sage ich mal. Es gibt andere Satelliten, die können durchaus ein, anderthalb Jahre hier verbleiben, weil die Anforderungen der Tests so hoch sind, dass wir auch selber uns erst schrittweise daran nähern müssen, um die Ergebnisse überhaupt interpretieren zu können. Herschel in diesem Zusammenhang ist zum Beispiel wieder ein sehr gutes Beispiel, weil da mussten wir auch erst lernen, wie wir richtig die Nutzlast vermessen können hier in unserem LSS, sodass wir sicher sein können, dass die Nutzlast auch wirklich unter den Weltraumbedingungen funktioniert. Das war also auch für uns ein Lernprozess, der dazu geführt hat, dass der Satellit auch länger hier war, als wir ursprünglich gedacht haben. Kommen wir auf ATV zurück. Das erste ATV hatte auch eine relativ lange Durchlaufzeit von einem Jahr im Test-Center. Das zweite, Johannes Kepler, was zuletzt gestartet ist, ist schon wesentlich kürzer hier gewesen. Und bei dem nächsten ATV wird zum Beispiel sogar schon darüber diskutiert, dass man bestimmte Tests wegfallen lassen kann.
Weil man sich da einfach sicher war, dass man das in der Zeit...
Da weiß man jetzt auch aus dem Flugdaten heraus, was es bedeutet und kann beurteilen, ob man den Test überhaupt noch machen muss oder nicht.
Das könnte sich dann sogar noch verbessern beim vierten und fünften Durchlauf.
Jaja, also die werden auf jeden Fall eine immer kürzere Umschlagzeit haben im Test Centre.
Ja, das war es eigentlich an Tests, die hier im Wesentlichen durchgeführt werden. Oder haben wir noch was vergessen?
Nein, ich denke, das sollte...
Das Ding wird angeschrien, das Ding wird gerüttelt und geschüttelt. Es wird von mehreren Sonnen bestrahlt, geht dann gut gebräunt ins Vakuum über. Und wenn auch noch die ganzen Komponenten untereinander sich nicht zu sehr durcheinanderbringen, dann gibt es hier irgendwie den Stempel, ESTEC Tested and Approved, darf ins Weltall.
Genau so ist das.
Und wie kommen die Dinger dann hier wieder weg? Ich meine, das sind ja auch so riesige Klötze, die müssen dann nach...
Da kommt der große Transporter, der sie auf die Ladefläche nimmt. Und das bringen wir dann irgendwann aufs Schiff, hier in der Nähe. Meistens fahren wir es bis Rotterdam, wo es dann aufs Schiff kommt. Und das Schiff fährt es dann rüber nach Coru, französisch Guiana, wo ja der Raumfahrthof der Europäer ist. Und von dort wird es dann gestartet.
Also wird nichts geflogen, es wird nur verschifft?
Wir fahren im Allgemeinen mit dem Schiff. Auch da natürlich wieder Ausnahmen. Wenn wir mit russischen Raketen starten, kann es durchaus auch sein, dass wir Satelliten fliegen. Weil der Transport in die russische Tiger mit dem Schiff teilweise doch was Aufwendiges ist.
Ja, aber man macht es eigentlich lieber mit dem Schiff, weil es nicht runterfallen kann.
Sicherheitsaspekt ist aber einfach auch ein Kostenaspekt. Wenn sie 20 Tonnen transportieren, dann ist das auf dem Schiff wesentlich preiswerter, als wenn sie in die Luft gehen.
Ja, haben wir es eigentlich, oder? Ja, ich denke, wir haben versucht, einen wichtigen Punkt noch übersehen.
Einen guten Überblick zu geben. Ja, das war auf jeden Fall schon mal ein guter Einstieg. Ich hoffe, das hat viele, viele Fragen aufgeworfen, sodass wir auch irgendwann mal zurückkommen und vielleicht auch in die ein oder andere Detail einsteigen können.
Denkbar, genau. Ansonsten gibt es unter raumzeitpodcast.de auch natürlich immer das begleitende Blog, in dem Kommentare hineingestellt werden dürfen, wo dann auch geguckt wird, dass man die kritischen Fragen auch beantwortet bekommt. Ja, ansonsten bleibt mir jetzt nur noch Dankeschön zu sagen. Jörg Wehner, für die Aussagen. Aha, jetzt funkt es doch nochmal dazwischen. Das wiederhole ich jetzt nochmal. Im Endeffekt hat es die ganze Zeit Ruhe gegeben. Gut, dann bleibt mir jetzt eigentlich nur noch Dankeschön zu sagen für die Ausführung. Jörg Wehner, hier über das ESTEC, das Test-Center. Vielen Dank auch fürs Zuhören. Und ich sag Tschüss und bis bald, bis zur nächsten Ausgabe von Raumzeit.